- Okay, I think third time did the trick.
Sorry for all the stops and starts.
As I mentioned, this is all very impromptu
and very improvisational, but yes,
now even this dashboard that I'm using
says that I'm online on at
least Facebook and YouTube.
So I will just keep going
and power through this
because I think there's
a little bit of a delay
between when I'm starting and stopping.
So it's I'm pressing start, it starts,
and then everyone says it's working,
but then by that time I
thought it wasn't working
and then I started again.
But I think we're good, I'm just gonna
keep powering through this.
I'll start over.
This, for those of you all who
are wondering where I'm am,
I'm in a walk-in closet
off of my master bedroom
because out here in
California we have these
stay in place orders, and as I mentioned,
this is the walk-in closet
where Khan Academy all got started.
I have spent a year in this
walk-in closet back in 2010,
so I'm prepared to spend
at least many weeks
or months in this walk-in
closet if necessary.
But as you can imagine, a lot going on.
For those of you that
this is the first time
that you're coming to this livestream,
the whole point of it is we obviously
have these mass school closures going on
and we, at Khan Academy we find ourselves
in a somewhat unique
situation of realizing
that this is what Khan Academy
to some degree was made for
even though we've never really thought
of this circumstance actually happening.
And this is clearly a very, situation,
I don't think anyone would want this,
the ideal circumstance is
that the schools are open,
Academy is somehow a substitute
for live experiences.
We've always imagined
them being in partnership
with incredible teachers and classrooms
and you have your peers and
you can liberate the classroom
to then go to higher order tasks.
But we've also imagined Khan Academy
being used in parts of the world
where students might not
have access to school
or might not have access to certain,
to instruction or curriculum
material of certain qualities.
And we now find ourselves in a situation
where most of the world
is going to find ourselves
in that second category.
So a couple of things are happening.
I've been taking questions from parents,
teachers, students, I would love
to get more student questions actually,
I know there's some concern
about the cancellation,
delays of some of the
SAT administration tests.
On Friday, we released some schedules
for students of different ages,
and one thing that we recommended for sure
for high school students is to
use our official SAT practice.
Obviously you can use us for math.
You can use us for the sciences,
you can use us for the social sciences,
but we also have the official SAT practice
that we partner with the College Board on.
And even if you aren't taking the SAT
or even if now your SAT has been delayed,
I encourage you to think about using that
because it covers math,
reading, and writing,
and it'll really make sure
that those skills don't atrophy
even if you aren't
taking the SAT any time.
And if you do end up taking
the SAT in the next three,
four months, it'll be real useful.
But what I would love to do
is make this as interactive
as possible, I'd love to take
questions from all of you.
I see, let's see if I
can scroll down here.
I got a question, I'm a foreign student
who's aiming for a
mathematics course in the USA,
what courses exactly should I
examine in Khan Academy site?
Are linear algebra and
multivariable calculus needed
and what tests I need to take?
Well, Muhammad, it depends what level
you're coming into the United States.
I just saw a comment
that Sal is getting old.
We all get old.
It depends what level.
If you're coming at the college level,
you would probably have to take something
like the SAT, there might also be things
like the TOEFL which is measuring,
I think it's Test of
English Language Fluency
or Fluency Language, something like that.
I forget the acronym.
But for those tests actually the level
of mathematics you need
is not overly advanced.
For the SAT, you really,
the level of math,
you really have to master algebra two,
and know it well, there's some
tricky questions on there,
but for the most part they're
algebra two questions.
And similar for the reading
comprehension level.
Things like linear algebra
or multivariable calculus,
which are typically a freshman
or sophomore level course
in college in the United States
are definitely not required
for entry level into college.
Obviously if you're thinking
about graduate studies,
linear algebra's especially
tends to be applicable
in a lot of the technical fields.
Let's see, other people
are asking questions.
Is Khan Academy in Mountain
View closed as well?
Yes, we have shut down the office.
It's actually by law now, unless you work
in our area at a healthcare
facility or a grocery store
or gas station, something
that's considered essential,
they are telling folks not to go to work.
All right.
So hi Sal, I'm a, this is from Basil,
hi Sal, I'm a 17-year-old
high school student
and I have been teaching
for around three years
for physics, chem, and
math, do you recommend
any sources to improve
someone's ability to teach?
That's a great question, I've
never had quite that question.
Think the number one
thing is really mastery
of the material yourself.
I think even for myself
when I first learned
a lot of that material in
high school and college,
I was a good student and I
understood it quite well,
but it would be great if,
when I started doing
Khan Academy, it would,
and sorry, for the team,
all these Slack questions
are coming across and it's making it
a little bit disruptive.
I'll look at the iPad in a second.
But to learn how to may be
practice teaching better,
obviously there's nothing
like teaching itself.
I highly recommend
trying to make resources
that cover that material
and I think you'll find
that you'll learn the
material a lot deeper.
Let's see, I'm gonna go to the questions
that the team is looking at.
Okay.
And so I'm looking at the doc, team.
And so I'm looking at the top of it.
So, yeah, and what's going on right now
is our team is looking
at the various streams
and then they are curating the questions
for look at, at this
iPad, so there's a lot
of home brew things going on here.
But I'm happy to continue
to answer questions.
I will look at the stream
that I see on this dashboard
and see what other questions people have.
Let's see, people have asked,
it seems like the quality is
subpar, my apologies for that.
I will try to, before tomorrow,
try to find a place in the house
that hopefully has better quality Wi-Fi.
I have four full bars here, but I guess
that's not doing the trick.
This is my first day that
I'm doing this at home,
so it'll hopefully get better every day.
So please ask any questions,
the team is looking at it,
they will update this doc
that I'm working from.
I don't see any of the questions just yet.
So one question J.R. Gilroy asks,
will you be leading a nationwide
SAT, ACT study session?
A great question, J.R.,
we, as part of our effort
to support everyone, we are
thinking about things like that.
As you can tell, even for this livestream
we're trying to figure out the technology,
but I hope that over the,
especially if this school shutdown
situation is protracted,
if it keeps going,
I hope that we can find
ways to support you
in multiple subjects and
SAT especially is one area
that we might able to
do either livestreams
or large-scale video conferencing
and help answer folks' questions.
So I hope that we can go
do something like that.
Any chance can students
access Khan Academy
through gaming platforms?
Unfortunately, that
does not exist just yet.
Let's see,
other questions.
Okay, Niurka Zapata
says I've been assisting
Khan students around,
not just students, it's been helpful,
I'm so happy I'm one of your ambassadors.
Oh, so for those of y'all who don't know,
we have a thousand teacher
ambassadors around the world
who are teachers but
they've been super users
of Khan Academy, and
they're also in their region
not just helping their own
students use Khan Academy
but they're helping
teachers help their students
use Khan Academy, so thank you Niurka
for being one of those
teacher ambassadors.
And one of the things that
we're brainstorming here
at Khan Academy and we would love ideas
from all of you and especially
our teacher ambassadors
are ways that teachers,
and I know teachers are also
sorting out their own lives
right now, their kids are at home.
They're trying to figure
out how to support
their own students.
But if this crisis or if the
school shutdown continues,
I hope we can find ways
to work with teachers
who might able to volunteer to,
and not just teachers,
anyone who might be able
to volunteer to help support students
around the world who right now are feeling
maybe a little bit socially distanced
and need more support above and beyond
what Khan Academy can do on its own.
Our hope is, we've released
those schedules on Friday
that Khan Academy is able to,
that we've been able to structure a day
so that students of most ages are able
to use Khan Academy for most subjects.
But we hope that that can be
supported with other things.
Yesterday we talked about ideas
like if there's a classroom
or a cohort of students
who are working on
something at the same time,
maybe they can share a
video conference link,
a Zoom or a Google Hangout,
where if any of them
have questions, they can go on,
it could maybe be staffed
by a volunteer parent
or by their teacher.
And we're going to think about ways
that we might be able to
do that at a larger scale
or maybe even give templates or directions
for anyone to be able to
do that type of thing.
Once again, none of this is ideal,
but we're lucky that we
have access to technology
and a lot of resources
that will hopefully,
if this happened 30 years ago,
we would've been a lot
tougher of a situation.
So that's our hope.
Let's see, so I have a question here,
does Khan Academy provide
social-emotional programs?
So Khan Academy historically
didn't explicitly
do social-emotional programs.
We tried to put some
social-emotional best practices
in our product experience
and even in our content.
What we're told, people
like some of our content
because it just feels relaxing and fun,
and sometimes improvised, kind of like
what you're seeing right now.
But what we've been doing over the years
is trying to think about other ways
that we can supplement our core content
and experience with
social-emotional programs.
We've had programs at
schools like LearnStorm.
The app, Khan Academy Kids,
that has been recently launched,
that was about a year and a
half, almost two years now,
that is for younger students
ages three to about six,
goes through the first grade standards,
and that does cover
social-emotional learning
above and beyond math,
reading, and writing
so as to develop some of that,
how do you deal with others
in cooperation and build your resilience?
But that is something that we hope
to explore further over time.
And let's see, other
questions that I might,
let me see.
Kay Gret says, do you think
that school will be canceled
for the rest of the year?
I'm not an expert,
although I'm not 100% sure that anyone
has a clear idea right now.
What I do know, I posted
a video on Saturday
about the virus itself
and about its spread,
and if you look at the
patterns in other countries,
the peak cases from the stage that,
and it depends who I'm talking
to in what part of the world
but if you're looking from
an American point of view,
it looks like the peak
cases start to level off
about two or three weeks
after, or maybe four weeks,
after there's a serious,
whether you call it a shutdown
or a stay in place.
Like here in California we
haven't had a full shutdown,
we're allowed to go outside,
but they are enforcing a stay in place.
So there's only some very basic
functions that are in place.
China, in Wuhan, did a full shutdown,
and so they probably saw pretty good,
and it still took them two to four weeks
to get to a leveling off period.
So in places like California
where it's not as full
of a shutdown, I hope that
can happen in that timeframe,
but even if you imagine that,
which I think would be
on the more optimistic
sides of things, it's
not that all of a sudden
people are gonna open up all
of the institutions at peak,
'cause the worst thing you want to do is
that things start to level off
and then you open everything up
and then things go back exponential.
So my best guess is that it's
going to be several weeks,
and you can imagine the school year,
at least in the Northern Hemisphere
we have about two months
left, 2 1/2 months left.
So I think it's possible that this goes
through the end of the school year.
Not an expert though.
Let's see.
So Isaiah Hong says, hi Sal, hi Sal Khan,
a fellow college student here.
Maybe I don't look so old to Isaiah,
he says fellow college student,
how will I know myself if I
have mastered the material
I've been studying, any
tips or key indicators
to know if I have demonstrated mastery?
Well, one of the key tenants
for those of y'all listening
and don't know about
mastery and mastery learning
at Khan Academy is this notion of mastery,
that in traditional academics oftentimes
you're exposed to the material
and maybe you, and then the class
might move on to the next subject.
And then that gap, and
maybe it's in something
pretty fundamental, it
might be in basic exponents.
Now all of a sudden
you go to the next unit
that's on negative
exponents, on logarithms
and you're expected to understand it.
And so Isaiah, I think there's
two ways to think about it.
There's kind of the
general term of mastery
that people use in everyday language,
and then the, I guess you'd
say more academic version
that we use called mastery learning
which is making sure that you
can learn at your own pace
and fill in all of your gaps.
So to answer your question as to
how do you know that you've mastered it,
I think the question maybe is mastered
at a certain degree of knowledge.
And that's why when you go, for example,
on math or in many of the
sciences on Khan Academy
we have what we call
these mastery mechanics.
So that for every skill you can,
you get to familiar,
proficient, or mastered
depending on, have you done
it on kind of skill-focused
practice, have you done it in kind of
a context switching
environment on our unit tests
or our course challenges?
So if you're on Khan Academy
and if you're in a course
and you get full mastery
by doing the unit tests,
the master challenges,
the course challenges.
On that course challenge, you
can get a 90-plus percent,
you will have mastered that content,
at least in the modalities
that Khan Academy
is presenting them to you.
If you want to go even
deeper in a subject,
especially in something like math,
then I expect, then I would go after
some of the more multi-part questions,
even for some of the
things like our AP prep
we have videos that go
into deeper questions
that you really can't
do in a multiple choice,
in a free response modality.
And there pause the video
before I work through it
or one of our video
creators work through it
and try to work through it on your own.
And I think if you're seeing
that, you'll have mastered it.
I think the next level may
be even above a mastery,
and this goes to a previous
question that someone asked is,
teach the material to other people.
That's really the best way to
ensure that you can master it.
Because if you can really
distill it in simple ways
and teach it to others, then
I think you know the material.
Okay, other question?
Yeah, and my apologies,
I've gotten multiple points
of feedback now that the
internet connection here
is not good.
So I'm going to try to fix this overnight
and have a better internet
connection for everyone tomorrow.
So let's see, other questions.
Kim McDonald, this is a parent, and says,
is there an easy way to
learn how to make assignments
for my kids?
I'm new here and I want
them working every day.
And so the simple answer is yes,
you can make assignments on Khan Academy.
You can actually register
using the teacher tools
as a parent and then you
could either add your child on
as one of your students
or there's a little code
and then they can add you on
as their coach or their teacher.
And then once you're a teacher,
if you go to any piece of content
you can actually see a little thing
that shows up at the top
that says you can assign it
and you'll only have one student
or however many children you have.
So, yes, you can assign content,
but I also encourage, especially
in subjects like math,
let your student learn
at his or her own pace
so that they can master
concepts at their time and pace
and that for you to support them,
answer any questions they might have
and provide some motivation.
See, other questions.
So someone asks, hey Sal, it's really hard
for me to concentrate at home, any advice
for finding motivation when you don't
have any outside pressure?
This is a very good question,
and I think this is
something that we all face,
especially now that most
of us, or all of us,
are going to be working from home.
But it's an important skill,
because especially once
you're out of school,
you know, my day, I don't
have someone saying,
hey, do this for the next hour
then do that for the next
hour, sometimes I do.
But the way to try to
do it is I give myself
a list of things that I hope
to accomplish in a given day
or in a given week and
what I do is as I'm able
to hopefully accomplish some of them,
and some of them are longer ranging things
that can't be done in an hour,
but some of them are things
that can be done that hour.
And it could be in progress
to something bigger.
And what I tell myself is if
I can knock this stuff out,
then I have earned a right to, whatever,
take a break, go for
a walk, whatever else.
I find that pretty motivating.
I think it's also motivating
just to remind yourself,
this is your opportunity to
really invest in yourself.
A lot of times I think students
maybe have the right mindset
to school where they're kind of just like,
oh, I gotta be here, what do I have to do?
But you have to realize school
is massive investment in you,
in your capabilities,
and now that you're home,
and we'll try to support
you as best as we can
and try to come up with more
mechanisms to support you,
but the simple answer
is this is your chance
to build that other muscle,
not just the algebra
or the reading
comprehension or the science
but build the muscle of
actually learning how to learn
and learning to self motivate here,
which I think is in some ways
the most valuable meta skill
you can have in life.
Okay.
I see someone asks, I
just missed a question,
that was an interesting one.
It says, what is, let me
get back on the questions
from the team.
Let's see, I have another question,
tips on how you make videos for students.
So I wish I could show
you my office right now,
which I'm not at because
of the stay at home orders
that we have here in Northern California.
But my setup is pretty simple.
I have a basic laptop,
actually this is the laptop
that I've recorded many
Khan Academy videos on.
I have a $150 Samson microphone.
You could probably find it online
or at a local electronics store.
Doesn't have to be that one,
just something that sounds decent.
It's not super, all out
professional microphone.
And I use a Wacom tablet to draw on,
so it's a tablet that you can write on
and it takes a little
bit of getting used to
but I've been doing it for 10 years now
so I'm very used to it, 14 years now.
On top of that, what I
use is a drawing program.
In the old days, I used Microsoft Paint,
then I ended up using other tools.
Now I use SketchBook
Pro as the art program
and then I use Camtasia
Studio to do screen capture
while I'm drawing on the art program.
So that is how I make the videos,
kind of the meta tips I would have
if you want to make videos
is just get started.
I think it's very easy to overplan
or to convince yourself you're not ready,
and there's nothing
like kind of jumping in
and getting started,
especially if your audience
is for people you know and you care about.
I think it was a blessing for me
that Khan Academy started with my cousins.
It allowed me to say, all
right, it's my cousins,
I'm just gonna press record
and see what happens.
But I think that allowed the videos
to be more conversational,
to be a little bit more comfortable.
You don't want to be super improvised,
but a little bit of improvisation is nice,
people can recognize that
it's not being constructed
by some corporation
with large focus groups,
et cetera, et cetera, it's one human being
trying to communicate
with another human being.
So I really encourage you,
I can't tell you how many,
I had friends that I tried
to recruit to make videos
in the early days of Khan Academy
and they're brilliant people
who know how to explain things,
passionate about their subject.
If I talked to them at
a coffee shop about it,
I'm like, oh, can I just record you?
'Cause the way you just
explained quantum physics
is inspiring and really
easy to understand.
Then as soon as I try
to make 'em do a video,
they would get all tight
and they'd be like,
okay, the next step is, and it's like,
what happened to you?
And I think sometimes you
can get into your head
and you're so concerned
what other people will think
that everyone gravitates to a safe space
and they try not to be themselves
and they try to be what they think
other people think an
expert should sound like.
So I wouldn't do that, I
would try to be yourself.
Have your personality out
there and be vulnerable
with your students.
But obviously feel very
comfortable with the material
and I think it'll come out just great.
Let's see, Jessica Swanepoel
says, not a question,
but want to say my daughter
followed the schedule yesterday
and loved it.
She was very excited to get
started again this morning.
Awesome, that's great news to hear
'cause we put the schedules
out over the weekend
and it's good to get feedback,
and positive feedback
helps sometimes.
But negative feedback is good too,
so everyone should be encouraged
to give negative feedback,
critical feedback, because that
was our first draft schedule
for students and we hope to
refine it as we learn more.
So also give us feedback
and just say, hey,
that period was a little bit too long
for students of that age or
actually she wanted to do more
but the schedule said
move on to the next thing
or that break was a little bit too long
or we have ideas for other
parts of the schedule,
let us know, we would
love to make that schedule
better and better.
Let's see, Heather Johnson
says, is Khan Academy free?
That's a question I love to answer.
Khan Academy is free, that's why we exist.
We are a not-for-profit organization
with a mission of providing
a free world class education
for anyone anywhere.
The next question you might
wondering is, how is it free?
'Cause it costs many millions
of dollars ever year,
many tens of millions of
dollars every year to put out,
even to start server costs
are $7 million a year,
and I have a feeling based on some
of the numbers we saw yesterday
that they're going to be in excess
of $10 million a year shortly.
That's paid for by
philanthropic donations.
And so I will say if any of you,
for those of you who are
in a position to donate,
you can go to khanacademy.org/donate.
If you find value from Khan Academy,
if you want to ensure
that it's up and running
as we go through this crisis that students
around the world who
don't have the resources
or don't have access to
high quality materials,
think about even a $5, $10,
one-time or monthly donation.
But that's how we are free for everyone.
Let's see, this is from Dishonest Abe,
I respect your honesty in your username.
Where do you get the emotional
energy to learn all the time?
You know, for me,
learning actually gives me
emotional energy, I tell a lot of folks
when they learn that Khan Academy
is now a 200-person-plus organization,
they kind of imagine that
I'm your traditional CEO
who might sit in a boardroom all day
and be in meetings all day,
and some of that is kind of true,
but I'm a fairly nontraditional CEO.
But for me, and all of
that's really important,
you have to have a team
that you get aligned,
that you can work with, that
you can do big things together,
because you're not gonna be
able to do it by yourself.
And this is true even beyond Khan Academy,
why we form partnerships
and things like that.
But for my emotional energy,
for me to be able to get
into the walk-in closet
or go into my office and to be able
to learn some new history or new science
or just to be able to
communicate something
that I've always loved,
which is almost everything
I ever learned, that's the stuff
that puts me in a good mood.
When I come home and I'm grumpy,
my wife will say, you probably
didn't make any videos today
and she's usually accurate.
I'm usually in a good mode
once I've had a chance
to immerse myself in
some academic content.
And I think the thing
you have to appreciate
is this content that
you're seeing in textbooks
or Khan Academy, almost every concept
someone had dedicated
their life to figuring out.
And sometimes people dedicate
their lives to figure out
and they couldn't figure it out.
They couldn't figure
out, how did plants grow,
how did they take carbon from the air
and use sunlight and water
to somehow store energy?
How do we know that A
squared plus B squared
is equal to C squared?
People pondered this
for sometimes decades,
hundreds of years, and
you have the answers.
And it's all there, and you just have
to decode it a little bit.
It's like you're Harry, and you're like,
wow, someone figured out all this stuff
and I can learn this magic without having
to go through all of
that and maybe one day
push the frontier.
So Dishonest Abe, I think it's just
if you look at it the right way,
it's incredibly magical and it could be
a source of emotional energy, of learning,
versus a drain on emotional energy.
So let's see, maybe we have
time for one more question.
And let's see, the
science enthusiast says,
my sister is struggling with fractions,
I want to teach her.
How can I teach her in
a way that she likes?
So I think the number one thing,
so if she's struggling with fractions,
I would go to Khan Academy's
section on fractions,
you can search on our page.
You can even actually go to arithmetic,
the whole arithmetic
course on Khan Academy,
there's a whole unit on fractions.
And I would start at the
beginning of that unit,
and I would have her work on that material
while you are sitting next to her.
Don't answer the questions for her.
You can give her little
pushes every now and then,
little nudges if she's
getting a little demotivated
or she needs a little bit of a reminder,
or you just need to say,
well, read the question again,
what are they really asking?
And see how she's doing.
If you think her question,
her problem is really in fractions,
then try to just answer any
questions she might have,
but always push her,
if she has a question,
say watch the video first.
Let her build that sense of agency
so that she can learn to learn
and you're there to support her.
But if the video isn't
properly explaining it
or it's just not resonating with her,
the hints to each of the exercise items
are not resonating with her,
then it's a great for saying,
okay, well let's think about it like this.
But I think the hardest thing
when you're doing it live
is the patience, and I say
that because people say
I sound very patient in
the videos, hopefully I do,
but sometimes when you're,
when I'm with my kids sometimes
and I feel like I'm, I think
their brain is drifting,
they're probably getting
frustrated with me
because they're thinking
dad's saying the same thing
over and over again and
it's not making progress.
So respect, appreciate that she is trying,
that she's not just drifting
and she's not listening to you
and just try to be as patient as possible.
I think that's where tutoring
session oftentimes break down.
The tutor gets frustrated,
the student gets frustrated,
and everyone wants to walk away.
So have that patience,
keep motivating her,
and I think little by
little, I saw this Nadia
back in the day in 2004
when I was tutoring her,
as long as you keep that regularity
I think you are going to
see a lot of progress.
If you see that even at the
earliest fractions thing,
so even adding 2/3 to 1/3
somehow she has some difficulties
with things like that,
it might be from gaps
that are coming earlier
in her learning journey
in some of the more basic arithmetic.
So that's another thing
that you might want to do
is have her start earlier
and build some confidence.
That's one thing we've been
recommending on the schedules
is having students maybe even start
as early as kindergarten.
For example, your sister
I'm guessing she's a third
or a fourth grade student,
start her on kindergarten,
and she'll get through that super fast.
She might learn a thing or two,
probably will take her half an hour,
an hour to get through kindergarten,
then first grade might take her an hour.
It'll build confidence.
She'll see that, okay, she can do this,
then second grade, then third grade.
If she gets to third grade, she's going
to start hitting her zone
of proximal development,
her learning edge, so to speak,
but she'll know that she's approaching it
with a very strong foundation.
And the more that you can
be around there for her,
the better, and motivate her.
So I will, I think that's all for today,
especially with all of
the technical difficulty.
Thanks everyone for being part of this.
This is one of the things
that keeps me happy
in this time of what
we call here in the US
social distancing to
hopefully stop the spread
of this virus, but I
really enjoy connecting
with all of you.
I hope that this provides
some form of connection
in this time of social distancing
for all of you as well.
And stay tuned, I'm
gonna do this every day
so that we feel together,
we want to support you
not only on your learning journeys
but just as human beings,
this is something,
one day someone will
do Khan Academy videos
about this time in history, 'cause it's,
I think it's pretty interesting.
So I will leave y'all,
and I'll see you tomorrow.